handelt sich im hinblick auf nord im 2
um ein privatwirtschaftliches vorhaben
und dass es sich bei dem
privatwirtschaftlichen projekt das mit
nord stream verbunden ist um ein
privatwirtschaftliches vorhaben handelt
über die 1200 kilometer stahl die die
private wirtschaft auf den grund der
ostsee legt haben regierungen verhandelt
haben parlamente gestritten haben hoch
über den bauarbeiten präsidenten und
kanzler geurteilt kaum ein land hält
nord stream 2 für einen rein
privatwirtschaftliches vorhaben außer
dass deutschland von kanzler scholz in
dem bestehen jetzt auf dem
privatwirtschaftlichen charakter von
nord stream zwei liegt eine unglückliche
public diplomacy denn
niemand außerhalb deutschlands versteht
diese kommunikation niemand versteht
weshalb man darauf bestehen kann den
politischen charakter von nord stream
zwei zu leugnen die spd leugnet nicht
die gefährdung des friedens der welt sie
droht russland mit schwerwiegenden
sanktionen mit der am schwersten
wiegenden droht sie nicht nicht intern
und nicht öffentlich mit dem aus für
nord stream 2 weil sich alles in mir
dagegen wehrt und das auch nicht unsere
überzeugung als spd ist dass man
potenzielle internationale konflikte
herbeireden sollte oder vielleicht sogar
eine gewisse obsessionen entwickelt
nämlich projekte auf diesem wege noch
beerdigen zu können die an schon immer
ein dorn in den augen gewesen sind
internationale konflikte herbeireden
eine obsession sogar ein unerhört
scharfe angriff in richtung grüne die
nord stream zwei als geopolitische
umgehung sehen als umgehung der ukraine
die russland vorantreibt um im
nachbarland freie hand zu haben heftig
widersprechen beide koalitionspartner
parteien der spd es geht nicht darum
hier konflikte herbeizureden es geht
darum nach dialog zu suchen aber wir
dürfen bei diesem dialog und bei diesem
dialog bemühungen auch nicht naiv sein
denn darüber lacht auch der kreml und
auch mittlerweile die ganze welt bessere
hier niemand internationale konflikte
herbei das projekt nutzt ihm zwei wird
in russland oder in den usa als
geostrategisches sowie politisches
projekt gesehen und es wäre wichtig das
ist auch in europa so gesehen wäre für
bundeskanzler brandt war die
verständigung mit moskau die ostpolitik
die leistung seiner kanzlerschaft
bundeskanzler scholz kündigt nicht
weniger an was wir brauchen ist eine
neue ostpolitik aber es ist diesmal eine
der europäischen union ist es
zuallererst eine europäische politik
ostpolitik kann im vereinten europa nur
eine europäische ostpolitik brandts idee
durch stärkere verflechtung gegenseitige
abhängigkeit zu schaffen war real
politik war damals neu und mutig man
muss den tatsachen ins auge schauen dass
es die tiefe der tiefere sinn der
entspannungs politik gewesen und aus
einer realistischen analyse des richtige
ableiten und das wäre heute im
europäischen verbund
gemeinsame politik machen sich nicht
spalten lassen und nord stream 2 ist in
dieser hinsicht leider ein großes
problem am beginn seiner europäischen
ost politik fehlt olaf scholz die
unterstützung europas
es ist unvorstellbar dass wir auf der
einen seite über sanktionen nachdenken
und auf der anderen seite diese
infrastruktur eröffnen
wie tief die verbitterung sitzt wie
stark vor allem in osteuropa das gefühl
ist nicht gehört zu werden klingt für
deutsche ohren mitunter erschreckend
die
politik der beschwichtigung nur weitere
aggression haben provoziert deswegen
sollten wir heute keinesfalls nicht die
fehler von
1938 wieder rollen es werden verheerende
vergleiche wach es werden noch bittere
und erbitterte kämpfe um eine pipeline
die angeblich ein rein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt ist